a follow does not mean an endorsement
a follow does not mean i agree
with everything they say and do to all
the haters trolling candace cameron
beret about who she follows on social
media
she has something to say i want to know
what's going on in the world i want to
hear
different sides of the argument on
thursday the fuller house star hit up
her insta story to address fans who have
recently voiced concerns over some of
the accounts she follows on twitter
and instagram people that were
disappointed or
or told me that they were unfollowing me
because
of the people i choose to follow on
instagram
and it's always strange to me because
i follow a very broad range of people
politically within my work industry
and then personal friends and things i
like the 44 year old actress didn't drop
specifics about which accounts
but she's following just over 1 100
people
including politicians like president joe
biden vp kamala harris
barack obama and donald and melania
trump
along with sarah huckabee sanders
candace owens and
some conservative media outlets a follow
does not mean an endorsement a follow
does not mean i agree with everything
they say and do
it just means i follow a broad range of
people so that
i have perspective i want to know what's
going on in the world i want to hear
different sides of the argument i follow
people
in entertainment that i don't
necessarily agree with
or act the same way but
i want to hear what our society what
culture is
dishing out i mean she makes a good
point
why thank you candace also points out
that she knows some people prefer to
only follow accounts that align with
their own thoughts and beliefs
and she understands that some people
probably have a hard time seeing posts
that offer up opposing views
but she says that so isn't her
i follow left and right but it doesn't
make my blood boil
i don't get angry at it so maybe it's
healthy for some of you not to follow
people you disagree with
but but it doesn't upset me it just
gives me perspective
of course this isn't the first time the
dancing with the stars alum
clapped back at the haters on social
media there's nothing like my family and
being home
back in december candace shared this
snap of her fam on instagram
that's candace her hubby val and their
three kiddos
22 year old natasha 20 year olds lev and
18 year old maxim cute right we are
thrilled
beyond thrilled well the trolls did what
the trolls do
and slammed the pic in the comments so
candace she jetted over to facebook and
shut that ish down hard quote
shame on you it doesn't matter if you're
10 or 90 years old
rude is rude be better than that i'm
praying for humanity
manners and respect if you don't like
something just move on
there are people and real feelings
behind every screen